thank you Yasser beg him first of all
congratulations a good start for your
2022 campaign how does this Victory feel
very important
these are kind of like
slow and it's a good win Good Start how
did you strategize let's say the opening
phase you started off with E4 C5 and it
did feel like after Bishop to D7 you
started thinking a little bit yeah
actually I didn't expect this six move
at all just for one second we're going
to interrupt you because Hans has won
his game against Christopher you and
starts his 2022 campaign with a crucial
Victory yes he does this he's the only
one that's hard to win the open back to
you Christian
again back to the position oh yeah I
didn't expect a D6 at all she never
played that that's why I was like okay
let's be a little bit creative because
main move is D4 which I play and I have
a lot of games there I was like
probably she's ready and I just started
to create I I knew some ideas but I'm
not sure if I did
uh
if I did the Right Moves A4 I just saw
at some point like A4 exists so
basically that's why not try why not try
it right
Knight to C6 Castle Knight to F6 where
do you feel comfortable with your
position E6 D4 I was surprised she
played Bishop G4 move I thought this
position should be slightly better for
me maybe she shouldn't be like spending
that's why after Bishop G4 I thought
maybe she's gonna take on F3 and try
something I I wasn't really sure
yeah just after I played G4 Bishop G2
Knight C3 like I felt like I was better
like slightly better not not much
and then we got to this position and he
played this uh nice prophylactic move
Queen to D2 which the panel was praising
um how did you feel about your chances
at this point uh at this point I thought
okay I don't have much but it was like a
playable position I just wanted to play
it and I was just waiting for her to to
shuffle her pieces more so I can
understand the position better and I
think whatever she did is not that great
but my reaction wasn't a very precise in
my opinion she played like Knight B6
here right
and she also started burning a lot of
time yeah and I was thinking a lot too
but it's understandable first day you
you want to like really go into the game
even though she was spending more time
because after D6 probably she didn't
expect Bishop B5 and it's it's a kind of
like new position for her too that's why
and then probably she was a little bit
afraid to like uh to do something very
very bad let's say that's why she was
just Spanish she was a little bit afraid
to play the position I guess it was more
familiar for me because I'm an E4 player
so it just didn't matter and you also
have more space it just feels like it
flows easier for you yeah I was thinking
maybe A5 is not that great maybe I just
had to play Rook D1 immediately it seems
like a good move to my eyes and to the
engine size as well so that's good A5 97
Knight A4 seems uh like you're building
up I was thinking maybe she was trying
to play Knight C5 but after D5
I thought that was already but still
it's a difficult position for black yeah
and she had to make a decision because
she only uh had seven minutes at this
point that's sure rotated one
so I think this was the critical moment
the next critical moment and she made
her move with something along the lines
I missed Bishop H4 and when we got this
position like before uh we got this
position before I took on D5 yeah before
I took on D5 I I just realized I missed
uh Bishop H4 because my idea was just to
take with the bishop and after 95 I
thought I was winning and that's why I
was a little bit angry at myself that I
missed Bishop H4 but I was like okay if
she finds it then a queen a four and
night before is uh is a threat that's
why it just decided to go it's not easy
it's not easy especially with a few
seconds on the Block we we both at this
point had like only a minute so I was
like okay if she finds it it's fine
we'll just keep playing it and it does
seem like the only way out might be
something like Rook to E2 okay this is
yeah this is not easy to find
um and if you don't find Rook to then
you're watching
that's why she didn't play Bishop H4 she
also thought after quitting F4 the night
before his coming I I to be honest I
thought that that's why that's the
reason why she didn't play but after
Bishop F6 Queen F4 suddenly she's just
losing yeah like there's no way
already you picked up the piece and
after that you finished in a nice
Fashion After Queen to uh f8 Queen takes
G7 and I was saying that we're going to
have a big discussion if you play Rook
to E8 instead of Queen takes G7 I was
very happy that she gave me the chance
to Checkmate her usually just people
resign earlier so it's nice to start
with a Checkmate absolutely
congratulations Bear game and we'll see
you in the next few rounds thank you now
congratulations to you as well a very
nice finish indeed